what is the phylogenetic tree or The
evolutionary of life and what can we
learn by running it back and studying
ancient Gene sequences as you have I
think phytogenetic trees
could be one of the most uh romantic and
beautiful Notions that can come out of
biology it shows us a way to depict the
connectedness of life and all living
beings with one another
it itself is an Ever evolving notion
biologists like visualizations they like
these Graphics these diagrams and tree
of life is one of them so the tree
starts at a common ancestor it's
actually the other way around it starts
from at the end it starts from the uh
from the branches it starts from the tip
of the branch actually and then the
further depending on how what you
collected uh to build the tree so
depending on the branches depending on
what's on the tip of the branch and I
will explain what I mean the root will
be determined by what is really sitting
on the tip of the branch of the tree so
we could study the leaves of the tree by
looking at what we have today and then
start to reverse engineer start to move
back in time to try to understand what
the rest of the tree what the roots of
the tree looks exactly so the tree
Itself by just taking a few steps back
and looking at the entire tree itself
can give you an idea about the
connectedness the relatedness of the
organisms or whatever again you use to
create your tree there are different
ways but in this case I'm imagining
entire diversity of Life Today is
sitting on the tips of the branches of
this tree and we
um look at biologists look at the the
tree itself we like to think of it as
the topology of the tree to understand
when certain
organisms or their ancestry may have
merged over time
depending on the tools you use you might
use this tree to then reconstruct the
ancestors as well
and so what are the different ways to do
the Reconstruction so you can do that at
the gene level
uh or you could do it at the higher
complex biology level right so what what
in which way have you approached this
this fascinating problem we approached
it in every way we can so it's the gene
could be protein the product of the gene
or species
or could be even groups of species it
will depend it totally depends on what
you want to do with your tree if you
want to understand a certain past events
whether an organism exchanged a certain
DNA with another one along the course of
evolution you can build your tree
accordingly if you rather use the tree
to reconstruct or resurrect ancient DNA
which is what we do then in our case for
instance we do both Gene protein and
species because we want to compare the
tree
that we create using these different
information
okay well let me ask you the ridiculous
question then so how realistic is
Jurassic Park
can we study the genes of ancient
organisms and can we bring the those
ancient organisms back so the reason I
asked that kind of ridiculous sounding
question is uh maybe gives us context of
what we can and can't do Yeah by looking
back in time yeah so uh dinosaurs or all
these mammals in in at least for us is
the exciting thing already happened by
the time we hit to the larger organisms
or to eukaryotes oh to you the fun stuff
is before we got to the memo the fun
stuff is what thing is boring I think
that the the phase that's well at least
two different times in the geologic
history one is the first life uh past
origin of Life how did first life look
like
and the second is why do we think that
over certain periods of geologic time no
significant Innovation happened to the
degree of leaving no record behind
so what do we not have a record of which
which part is it you the fun stuff to
you is after the origin of Life which
we'll talk about after the origin of
Life they're single cell organisms the
the whole thing with the photosynthesis
the whole thing with the eukaryotes and
uh multi-cell organisms and uh what else
is the fun stuff the whole oxygen thing
which mixes in with the origin of Life
uh there's a bunch of different
inventions all that have to do with this
primitive kind of looking organisms that
we don't have a good record of so I will
tell you the more interesting things for
us one is the origin of life or what
happened uh right following the
emergence of Life how did the first
cells look like
and then pretty much anything that we
think shaped the environments and were
was shaped by the environments in a way
that impacted the entire planet that
enabled you and I to have this
conversation
we have very little understanding of the
biological innovations that took place
in the past of this planet
we work with a very limited set of
um I don't want to even say data because
they're fossil records so let's say
imprints either that comes from the Rock
and The Rock record itself
or what I just described these trees
that we create and whatever we can infer
about the past so we have two distinct
ways that comes from geology and biology
and they each have their limitations
okay so right so there's an interplay
the geology gives you that little bit of
data
and then the biology gives you that
little bit of kind of constraints in the
materials you get to work with to infer
how does this result in the kind of data
that we're seeing and now we can have
this through the fog we can see we can
look back hundreds of millions of years
a couple of billion years and try to
infer even further and and I like that
you said [ __ ] it is pretty foggy but
weird and it gets foggier and foggier
the more you the further you try to see
into the past
um biology is you you basically study
with study the survivors
broadly speaking yeah and you're trying
to pitch the sort of put together their
history based on whatever you can
recover today what makes biology
fascinating also let it
erased its own history in a way right so
you work with this four billion year
product that's genome that's the DNA
it's great it's a very Dynamic ever
evolving
chemical thing and so you will get some
information but you're not gonna get
much unless you know where to look
um because it is responding to the
environment
yeah so what we have it's fascinating
what we have is the survivors the
successful
the successful organisms even the
Primitive ones even though the bacteria
you have today so bacteria is not
uh sorry sorry to offend the bacteria
it's we should be very grateful to
bacteria and first of all they are our
great great ancestors I like this quote
by Douglas Adams humans don't like their
ancestors they rarely invite them over
for dinner yeah right
that bacteria is in your dinner bacteria
is in your gut but today is helping you
for dinner we might well they get
themselves invited in a way yes and so
we and they're definitely older
um and and definitely very sophisticated
very resilient than anything
um else is someone working at the as a
bacteriologist I feel like I need to
defend them in this case because they
don't get much shout out maybe think
about life so you do study bacteria so
which organisms gives you hints that are
alive today that give you
um hints about what ancient organisms
were like it's bacterias viruses what do
you study in the lab we study a variety
of different bacteria depending on the
questions that we are
the engineer bacteria so ideally we want
to work with bacteria that we can
engineer seldom we developed the tools
to engineer them
and it depends on the question that we
are interested in if we are interested
in connecting the biology and geology to
understand the early life and and
fundamental Innovations across billions
of years there are really good
candidates like cyanobacteria so we we
use cyanobacteria very frequently in the
lab we can engineer its genome we can
perdurp its function by poking its own
DNA with the foreign DNA that we
engineer in the lab we work with E coli
it's the most simple in in terms of
models systems go goes organism that one
can study well-established sort of a pet
lab pet that we use it a lot for cloning
and for understanding uh or basic
functions of the cell given that it's
really well studied so and what you do
with that E coli you said that you
injectable foreign DNA we inject as much
all the bacteria that we work with with
foreign DNA we also work with
diazotrophs these are azodobacteria
they're one of the Prime nitrogen fixers
nitrogen fixing bacteria can you explain
what that is nitrogen fixing is that is
the source of its energy so nitrogen is
a triple bond gas
gets pretty abundant in the atmosphere
but
itself cannot be directly utilized by
cells given it as triple bond
it needs to be converted to ammonia that
is then used for the
Downstream
cellular functions and that's what
causes nitrogen fixing yes needs to be
fixed before our cells can make use of
it and and it's no offense to nitrogen
either well uh it's actually a very
important element it's one of the most
abundant elements on on our planets that
is used by biology it's in ATP it's in
chlorophyll um that's uh uses that
relies on nitrogen so it's a very
important enzyme for a lot of cell
functions and there's just one mechanism
that Evolution invented to convert it is
so far we know there's there's only one
nitrogen fixation pathway as opposed to
say carbon you can find up to seven or
eight different carbon based microbes
invented to fix carbon that's not the
case for nitrogen it's a it's a
singularity across geologic time we
think it evolved around 2.7 maybe
um roughly three probably less than
three billion billion years ago and
that's the only way that nature invented
to fix the nitrogen in the atmosphere
for the subsequent use would we still
have Life as we know today if we didn't
invent that nitrogen fixing step I
cannot think of it no it's it's it's
essential to Life as we know you you and
I are having this conversation because
life found a way to fix nitrogen is that
one of the tougher ones if you put it
sort of uh oxygen
nitrogen carbon what are in terms of
being able to work with these uh
elements
what is the hardest thing what is the
most essential for life just to give
context well we think of this as the
cocktail you may hear what's in the
cocktail it's the schnapps right carbon
hydrogen oxygen nitrogen sulfur so there
are five elements that life relies on
we don't quite know whether that's the
only out of many options that life
necessarily needs to operate on but
that's just how it have it happen on our
own planet and um there are many abiotic
ways to fix nitrogen uh and like
lightning right lightning can accumulate
ammonia
humans found a way about a hundred years
ago I think around World War One the
Haber bash process that we can
abiotically convert nitrogen into
ammonia actually 50 percent of the
nitrogen in our bodies comes from the
human
conversion of nitrogen ceremonia it's
helped it's the fertilizer that we use
urea comes from that process it's it's
not food so we helped we found a way to
fix our own nitrogen for ourselves yeah
but that you know that's way after the
original invention oh absolutely
absolutely and without that we wouldn't
have
we wouldn't have all the steps of
evolution along the way oh absolutely
it's very we tried to replicate in the
most simplest way what Nature has come
up with
right we do this by taking nitrogen
using a lot of pressure and then
generating ammonia life does this in a
more sophisticated way relying on one
single enzyme called nitrogenase it's
the nitrogen that is used together with
eight electron donor and ATP together
with a lot of hydrogen life pushes this
metabolism down to create
fixed nitrogen it's quite remarkable so
the lab pet E coli inject them with DNA
those are the so you call it as nitrogen
fixing in part or is that what's that a
different one so some logical Engineers
Engineers E coli to fix nitrogen I
believe not not us we use the Nature's
nitrogen nitrogen fixing bug and
engineer it with the nitrogen fixing
metabolism that we resurrected using our
computational and phylogenetic tools how
complicated are these little organisms
what what are we talking about it
depends on how you Define complication
okay so I I could tell that you uh
appreciate and respect the full
complexity of even the most seemingly uh
primitive organisms because none of them
are primitive okay that said what what
kind of what what are we talking about
how how
um
what kind of machineries do they have
that you're working with when you're
injecting them with DNA so I will start
with one of the most fascinating
machineries that we target which is the
translation machinery it is on a very
unique uh subsystem of cellular life in
comparison to I would say metabolism
and uh we used to
um you know when we are thinking about
cellular life we think of cell as the
basic units or the building block but
from a key perspective that's uh not the
case that one may argue that everything
that happens inside the cell serves the
translation and the translation
Machinery there is a nice paper that
called this that entire cell is
hopelessly addicted to this main
informatic
Computing biological chemical system
that it is operating at the heart of the
cell which is the translation it is the
translation it's translating from what
to what so RNA to enzymes it converts a
linear sequence of mRNA into a folded
later folded protein that's that's when
the uh that's the core processing center
for information for life it's uh has
multiple steps it initiates it elongates
its terminates and it recycles
it operates uh
discrete bits of information it's itself
is like a chemical decoding device and
that is incredibly unique for
translation that I don't think you will
find anywhere else in the cell that does
this so even though it's called
translation it's really like a factory
that reads the schematic
and builds a three-dimensional object
it's like a printer I would divide it
into actually even four more additional
steps or disciplines than what would it
take to study it by the way you
described it it's a chemical system it's
the compounds that make it up are
chemicals it's physical it's uh tracks
the energy to make its job to do its job
it's informatic what is processed are
the bits it's computational the discrete
states that the system is placed when
the information is being processed
that's itself is computational and it's
biological it's a there's variability
and inheritance that come from imperfect
replication even and infer imperfect
computation so you're and that's so good
so from the biology comes the like when
you mess up
the bugs of the features that's the
biology informatics is obvious in the
RNA that's a set of information there
the different steps along the way is
actually kind of what the computer does
with with bits its own computation
physical there's a uh I guess the the
like almost like a mechanical process to
the whole thing that requires energy and
actually you know it's manipulating
actual physical objects
and uh chemicals because you're
have to ultimately it's all chemistry
yeah and track system for me information
so it is almost a mini computer device
inside ourselves yeah and that's the
oldest uh computational device of life
it's it's uh likely the key uh operation
system that had to evolve for life to
emerge it's uh more interesting
or it's more complicated in interesting
ways than the computers we have today I
mean everything you said which is really
really nice I mean I guess our computers
have the informatic and they have the
computational but they don't have the
chemical the physical or the biology
exactly and and the computers don't have
don't link information to function
right they are not tightly coupled
nowhere close to what translation
or the way translation does it so that's
the number one I think difference
between the two
and um yes it's it's informatic and we
can um uh discuss this further to 100
let's please discuss this further which
part are we discussing for each one of
those are fascinating worlds each each
of the five yeah so about we can start
with the more I guess the the ones that
are more established which is the the
chemical aspect of the translation
Machinery it's uh the specific compounds
make up the Assembly of RNA chemists
showed this in many different ways we
can rip apart the entire Machinery we
know that at the core of it there's an
RNA that's
um
that operates not only as an information
information system itself or information
itself but also as an enzyme and and
origin of Life chemists make these
molecules easily now we know we can
manipulate RNA we can make even with
single part chemistries we can create
compounds what's a single part chemistry
um that's I would say when you add all
the recipes that you know that will lead
you to the final products
do is they they come up with this pod
they throw a bunch of chemicals in and
they try to try to they're basically
Chefs of a certain kind I'm not sure if
that's what they call it but that's how
I think of it because it is all combined
in a test tube and you know the outcome
and uh and it's it's mathematical once
you know the right environment and the
right chemistry that needs to get into
this container or the spot you know what
the outcome is there's no luck there
anymore it's a pretty rigid established
uh input output system and it's all
chemistry so you actually wear a lot of
hats as one of them original life
chemist my PhD is in chemistry but I
don't do origin of Life chemistry but
you're interested in origin of Life yes
absolutely so some of your some of your
best friends the original life chemists
just make sure that you have good
chemist friends if you're interested in
origin of Life yeah that's a hundred
percent requirement should be mandatory
okay so chemistry uh so what else about
this Machinery that we need to know
chemically well uh chemically I think
that that's it you have enzymes you have
proteins the enzymes are doing their
thing they know how to chew energy using
ATP or GTP they they know what to do on
their in their own way they do their
enzymatic thing so it's not just the
ribosome that is at the heart of the
transition but there are a lot of
different proteins you're looking about
a hundred different components that
compose this Machinery uh well let me
ask kind of maybe it's a ridiculous
question but did the chemistry
make this machine or did the machine
use chemistry to achieve a purpose
so like
um
I guess there's a lot of different
chemical possibilities on Earth
is is this much translation Machinery
just like uh choosing picking and
choosing different
chemical reactions that it can use to
achieve a purpose
uh or did the chemistry basically
like uh there's like a momentum like a
constraint to the thing that can only
build a certain kind of Machinery that's
basically is is chemistry fundamental or
is is it just emergent like how
important is chemistry to this whole
process you cannot have
chemistry
we need
process without
chemistry what makes life interesting is
that even if the chemistry isn't perfect
even if there are accidents along the
way if something binds to another
chemical in in a way it shouldn't
um there is resilience within the system
that it can maybe not necessarily repair
itself but it moves on have everything
perfect
mistakes can be handled that's where the
biology that's where the biology comes
in but in terms of chemistry you
absolutely cannot have a translation
Machinery without chemistry and so
you're as I said there are four main
steps these are the core steps that are
conserved in all translation missionary
and I should say all life has this
machine right
every cell everything on Earth on Earth
yeah yes when you think of this machine
do you think very specifically about the
kind of Machinery that we're talking
about or do you think more
philosophically a machine that converts
information into function it's I I
cannot separate
Machinery fascinating
those five components that I listed are
they coexist
so for instance if we uh let's just
talking about the chemistry part
um
we we know the certain
um rate constant all these proteins that
operate in this Machinery needs to
Harbor in order to get the mechanism
going
right if you are bringing the the
information to the translation
missionary and you're the initiator of
this computation system you need to have
uh you can only afford a certain range
of mistakes if you're too fast then the
next message cannot be delivered fast if
you're too slow then you may stall the
process so there is definitely a
chemistry constant going on within the
Machinery
um again it's it's not perfect far from
it but they all have their own margin of
error that they can tolerate versus they
cannot otherwise they call that the
system collapses so it's like a Jazz
Ensemble the notes of the chemistry but
you can be I love that you said yes it's
definitely true it's a party and it's
like everybody's invited and and and
they need to operate together right and
and they um what's really cool about it
I think or there are many things that
are very interesting about this thing
but if you take if you remove it from
the cell and put it in a Cell free
environment it works just fine right so
you can get cell free translation
systems uh put this transition in a test
tube and it is
doing its thing it doesn't need the rest
of the cell to translate information of
course you need to feed the information
at least so far
um it but because we are far from
evolving a translation maybe not so far
uh evolving a translation in the lab or
the Machinery that can process
information as it generates it we have
not done that yet it's a pretty
complicated Machinery so it's hard for
it to for those uh origin of Life
chemists to find a part that generates
because it's far more than chemistry you
need you need uh biology obviously you
need biochemistry you need to think as a
I think a network systems folk you need
to think about computation you think
about information and and that is not
happening yet except we are trying to
bring this perspective but the more you
understand how the information systems
work you cannot once you see it you
cannot unsee it it's one of those things
so but you can still it out and the
chemistry happens yes and chemistry can
happen even with even if you strip some
of the parts out it can you can get very
minimal level of information processing
that does not look anything like the
translation that cells relies on but
that what chemists showed from linear uh
you can generate information that
arrives to a processing center in the
form of a linear polymer
but the informatic part of this system
that I think sets it apart from
computation and from metabolism comes in
if you think about the information
itself right so we have four nucleotide
letters that compose DNA and they are
processed in the translation in triplets
so you have in in triplet codon
fragments so you have four times four
times four so you have 64 possible
states that can be encoded
by four letters in three positions
all right so it's so amazing yeah it's
so amazing there is only one code that
says start that's that there's only one
and then there's two if not three that
says stop
so that's that's what you work with but
you can have 64 possible States but life
only uses 20. amino acids so we used six
live users 64 possible States minus four
of the starts and stops to code for 20
amino acids in different combinations
that is really amazing if you think
about there there are 500 different
amino acids life can choose right it's
narrowed it down to training we don't
know why a lot of people think about
this genetic code is quite fascinating
right I mean it didn't do it for four
billion years I don't know we may wait
for another four billion years but but
you didn't have those amino acids in the
very beginning right like you don't know
so it we would be fooling ourselves if
we said we know exactly how many amino
acids existed early on but there's no
reason to think that it it wasn't the
same or similar yeah we don't we don't
have a good reason but
but because roughly 20 out of 60 states
are used you're using one-third of your
possible states in the in your
information system so it this may seem
like a waste but informatically it's
important because it's abundant and it
is uh redundant right so so this code
degeneracy you see this in that's
implemented by this translation
missionary inside the cell
so it means we can make errors right you
can make errors but the message will
still get through you you can speak
missing some letters to the information
can miss some parts but the message will
still get through so that's two-thirds
of the not used States give gives you
that robustness and resilience within
this system so at the informatic level
there's room for error there's probably
room for probably in all five
uh categories we're talking about
there's probably room for air in the
computation that's probably wrong from
area there's yes exactly everywhere yeah
because because the the informatic
capacity is made possible together with
the other
um components and not only that but also
the the product yields
a function no
in this case enzyme are pretty right so
so
that's really amazing for me it is I
mean I mean in my head just so you know
because I'm a computer science AI person
the the parallels between even like
language models that encode language
or now they're able to encode basically
any kind of thing including
um images and actions all in this kind
of way
the the parallel in in terms of
informatic and uh computation
is just incredible